Mark: HELLO EVERYBODY, WE'RE BACK!
We're gonna play more Rust.
My name is Markiplier, that's Bob.
Mark: Hey!
*THAT ZOOM*Bob: Oh, hey
Mark: Okay.
Mark: Alright, let's GOOOO!
Mark: Alright, y-you lead the way this time,
Mark: I - I led the way last time.
Bob: I think we should go to that town that I had seen.
Mark: Oh, you saw another walled-in town over there?
Bob: Yeah.
Mark: It's probably irradiated, but I think that's gonna be okay.
Bob: There's also these boxes that I'm interested in getting.
Mark: Oh, yeah, that's true.
Mark: Ooo there's another crate over here.
Bob: That one had a spring.
Mark: This one has a can of tuna and an apple.
Bob: Neat.
Bob: We need that food stuff, 'cause I don't know how really to get food in this game.
Mark: Yeah you- well, I mean, you just gotta scavenge until you can find a way to farm it I think.
Bob: Yeah, except there's no efficient way to scavenge it!
Mark: Yeah that's true too.
Bob: I was desperately searching for food the whole time when we were looking for each other and I found, like, an apple and a can of tuna.
Mark: Well-
Bob: In total.
Mark: Ideally, you find more rocks and get more wood,
and then you're able to hunt the deer and that should probably keep you fed for a long time, right?
Bob: Yeah i still dont know what rocks look like, so...
Mark: Well, I mean, I will show you if we ever come across it.
Mark: But I have not come across one.
Mark: I don't think-
Bob: You think with all those rocks we had seen, that those might have had been rocks?
Mark: Y- No
Bob: But they weren-
*f^ck up noises* Mark: WaaHey! Don't go in there!
Bob: Oh Jesus Cripes! (Cripes Bob?)
Mark: Ho!
Mark: Woah, I'm just gonna get some wood for a bit.
Mark: Jeez, well, my health is going down. That's great.
Bob: How much did you get? I got 20 Radiation Poisoning.
Mark: I got a good 18 or so. I tried to warn you, but then it's just like you were barreling in there!
Bob: Well I was sprinting in behind you and
Bob: all you said before I got there was "HAOoo! WOW!"
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: That could've been anything.
Bob: And I was like, "Oh, that could be good or bad, I don't know."
Mark: *laughs* Could've been a whole depository of FOOD and GUNS and ammo and armor! (You keep dreaming Mark)
Bob: Could even be a boat, who fucking knows?
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: I mean, hey, if I found a boat, I'd be pretty excited about it.
*turns into obnoxious cartoon character* Bob: "Waho! Woah ho! Waao!"
Mark: *laughs*
Happy Mark: "Boats! Boats! Boats!"
disappointed Mark: Uhp, my tree disappeared.
Bob: I'm gonna make a bow. How much do you need? You need cloth for a bow.
Mark: Mmhm
Bob: Fuck.
Mark: Where is the more-?
Bob: I've got lots of WOOD!
Bob: Like a serious boner for wood!
Mark: It used to be that you could just chop rocks and get stone out of it. Why is it so hard to get stone these days?
Mark: This stone? Nope, that not the right rock.
Bob: Why am I double-crafting hammer? I just want one hammer.
Mark: Oh yeah, what does hammer do?
Bob: Can't I just have one hammer?
Bob: I assume- *breathes in* WAIT! I remember!
Mark: Oh?!
Mark: OHH!
Bob: We're fucking dumb!
Mark: What?
Bob: You HAMMER rocks to get ROCKS! (or so you thought you're close)
Mark: Oh, you can't ROCK to get ROCK? (NOPE)
Mark: You can't ROCK rock to get ROCK?
Bob: But you can HAMMER rocks to get ROCKS! (He thinks he's got it)
Mark: Can you? (not at all)
Bob: Nope, not these ones.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: I'm not sure what the hammer's for. (nothing)
Mark: Yeah, that's not how.
Bob: Can we get SOME explanation on the hammer?
Mark: Nah nah nah.
Bob: The hammer used to upgrade building materials *quietly* and i hit the thing
Bob: *pause* *in the "You've Got Mail" voice* right click for the options.
*intense ZOOM* Bob: Fuck.
Mark: Ha ha.
Bob: Whatever, I have a hammer now, motherfucker!
Mark: Alright, I'm gonna see how much radiation is in this town... Not much!
Mark: Nothing yet! *le gasp*
Bob: Alright, good job Bob!
Mark [high pitched]: Good job Bob, good job!
Bob: Didn't there used to be like, zombies or something in this game?
Mark: Hang on, wait, I found a door. I'm gonna rock my way through it.
Bob: Is that you, slamming around the door?
Mark: No, it looks like someone BUILT a door here.
Bob: I'm gonna-
Mark: I'm gonna rock my way in!
Bob: I'm over to your left, crossing very slowly and cautiously.
Mark: Yeah, okay.
Mark: Woohp uhp!
Bob: If anything goes wrong, I'll just start yelling.
Mark: Oh this- Oh, there's- SURPRISE!
Mark: There was another DOOR behind the door!
Bob: Oh neat!
Mark: Yeah, I don't know how that worked, but okay. Looks like this guy built multiple doors here, didn't want anyone getting in.
Mark: Okay! There was another DOOR behind that DOOR! Why are there so many doors stacked on each other here?
Bob: There's a Recycler, and a Crafting- There's a Repair Bench in here.
Mark: Ooo! That sounds good!
Bob: But I don't have anything that's worth repairing!
*both giggle*
Mark: FUCKING! It's just nonstop doors upon doors here!
Mark: This is fucking bullshit.
Bob: Did you try OPENING them?
Mark: No, it's like wooden- It's just boarded up, that's all it is.
Bob: Oh okay.
Bob: Well-
Mark: I'm gonna- My rock is gonna disappear.
Mark: My hammer didn't do anything. GODDAMMIT! It's anothe-
Mark: It's ENDLESS doors here! This is NOT gonna work.
Bob: *giggles*
Mark: Fuckin' god damn it.
Bob: It's fuckin' door-pocalypse up in there!
Bob: Well this is like spooky and cool, but I'm not getting SHIT.
Mark: Yeah...
Bob: I'm not getting any loot at all.
Mark: Yeah, I see you way over there.
Mark: Yeah, there's nothing over here. Whoops.
Bob: Oh, there's a Can in here that I can bash open.
Bob: You hear that action?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: That's some sweet action.
Mark: That's pretty sweet bashin', dude.
Bob: Had literally nothing in it? Are you shitting me?
Mark: *groan*
Bob: Alright, well.
Mark: Alright, I'm gonna- I'm gonna...
Bob: Do we need to explore down into this ravine?
Mark: Oh, shit.
Mark: You can throw your rock. Did you know that?
Bob: OH! There's RADIATION in there!
Mark: Wooh!
Bob: Ah, fucks sake, I have 68 Radiation Poisoning!
Bob: I'm just gonna straight up die now.
Mark: That sounds like death.
Mark: Okay! Meet you back at the sleeping bags, buddy!
Bob: It's a race! I wonder who will win!
Mark: *giggles*
Bob: Well whatever, if I'm already gonna fucking die, fuck it, I'm going in here.
Mark: Alright, good luck!
Bob: I died.
Mark: Yay! Okay, I see you back in 'nother life.
Bob: Oh, thank god I'm alive again!
Bob [sarcastic]: Woohoo!
Mark: We should play Second Life, is what we should play.
Bob: THAT was fruitful!
Bob: Second Life? What is that?
Mark: You never heard of- You've heard of Second Life.
Bob: No, of course not. I haven't heard of that.
Mark [softly]: Everyone's heard of Second Life!
Bob: That's presumptuous.
Mark:  Every One's heard of Second Life.
Bob: ........
Bob: That's still presumptuous, just 'cause you say it differently doesn't-
Mark [softly growling]: Ev- Everyone's heard of Second Life, man.
Bob: ...no...
Mark [softly]: Dude.
Bob: Well now it just sounds like my music is broken.
Bob: It's just like, I don't think it's supposed to be like this.
Mark: Where'd you go? Where'd you go?
Bob: I'm at the BabSacks.
Mark: Ok. Oh THERE, I see.
Bob: I'm to your left on the hill.
Mark: Okay, let's go a different way, because I know there are a lot of rocks over this way.
Mark: I found 'em on the way here, and then it was just like a desolate wasteland.
Bob: Alright.
Bob: Let's do that shit.
Mark: And I know that we need rocks.
Bob: I'm gonna scavenge THIS though, before we go.
Mark: Ok, you do that.
Bob: I got some water AND some food!
Mark: Nice... God, you're so good at this game.
Bob: You're the hunter, but I'm the gatherer!
Mark [softly]: Nice, nice man!
Bob: With my deep, deep voice.
Mark: With your, sweet baps!
Bob: *giggles* Do you like the way my baps jiggle when I run?
Mark: Yeah, yeah man.
Mark: Yeah I swear over- Where'd you go?
Bob: I'm right here
Mark: Ok. Over this wayyyy, there's fuckin', hemp and stuff.
Bob: It's just gonna be rocks-a-plenty, huh?
Mark: NO! Maybe, I don't know! I can't believe we're STRUGGLING! To get FUCKING ROCKS!
Bob: Yeah, I mean I've seen lots of other random crap so far, but I haven't actually collected a rock.
Mark: I swear...
Bob: And there are SO MANY ROOOOCKS!
Mark: I swear... Wait, here! Right here! Right here!
Bob: Oh, hey! It's a stone.
Mark: It's a STOOONE. You can tell how its different than all the other rocks!
Bob: So the problem is that I don't want rocks, I want STONE!
Mark: TRUE!
Bob: I was had looking for the wrong THING.
Mark: RIGHT
Mark: If you uh, had-ta-had-ta known that
Mark: you would've gotten it right.
Bob: I would have had do that MUCH sooner
Mark: But NOW I have... problem, 'cause my fuckin'
Mark: bow disappeared
Mark [mumbled]: so I gotta make another one
Bob: (laughing) Just standin' there with a dead-eye stare
Bob: right through me
Mark: *laughs heartily*
Mark: He's walkin' up slowly with a rock like
Mark: "I'm gonna bash your face in,"
Mark: (Quietly suffocating) "Aye, fucking, goddamn it"
Bob: I think it'd be really funny, just as like an April Fool's
Bob: joke or something
Bob: If the dev's put it so that whenever anyone tried
Bob: to use the in-game voice chat, they would
Bob: they would push the push-to-talk and then it was just like
Bob: *walrus mating noises*
Mark: Woah, what the fuck is Sulfur Ore?
Mark: I just got that
Bob: Its stiiinky pee-yew!
Mark: *groans*
Bob: *snickers*
Mark: SO, apparently this--
Bob:-- Told you I was savin' that good stuff for this.
Mark: Yeah this is good,
Mark: also i'm about to die.
Mark: I'm low on--
Mark: foo-
Bob: I got food and water, ya need stuff?
Mark: Uh, nah, you can hold onto that, I'm going tooo
Mark: I'm gonna dooo, I'M gonna, try to HUNT!
Bob: Just-just wham that shit with your rock
Bob: Just who- "who fuckin' cares"
Mark: Yeah man, why wouldn't I?
Mark: Just tryin' to see if it'll work, man.
Mark: ALRIGHT, we should-we should OK
Mark: WE need to come up with a unified goal that's...
Mark: besides just not dying
Bob: I'm just running around...
Bob: ..near you. I mean, "Not dying" I  feel like is pretty ambitious as it is.
Mark: True, very true. But we need like a long term-
Bob: You mean it would be easier...
Bob: ...not to die if we were more specific?
Mark: Yeah!
Mark: Hey, wait, there's another town over here.
Bob [sarcasm]: Yeah, that was really helpful last time we found a town.
Mark: Well, I mean, it could be something.
Bob: This time it's bound to be more gooder.
Mark: I mean-
Bob: These rock formations are fucking amazing.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: I gotta say, I wish I had surreal rock formations near me.
Mark: Yeah, not bad.
Mark: Uhh apparently I'm starving now, but my health isn't going down,
Mark: so I think I'm okay.
Bob: I got food, man, I got extra food.
Mark: Yeah, but I've only got 30 food.
Mark: Or, I've got 30 food, so it should-
Mark: It should might last me.
Bob: I know you're trying to lose weight, Mark. It's the new year and everything,
Bob: But starving yourself isn't the way.
Mark: Nah man, I got it all under control, just, don't worry about it.
Bob: You gotta do it responsibly.
Mark: No, I got it, don't worry about it.
Bob: No... You've been at the gym, like 8 hours a day.
Bob: You haven't seen the kids all week.
Bob: I'm not comfortable with this, Mark.
Mark: Honey, it's fine, it's okay, it's all under control!
Bob: And you're sprinting away from me full-speed right now. What does this say about our relationship?
Mark: I- Just- You gotta get CARDIO in whenever you CAN, KAREN!
Mark: YOU GOTTA DO IT, IT'S IMPORTANT!
Mark: Tony Horton told me so.
Bob: *Who* is Tony Horton? You keep mentioning that like I know that person.
Mark: He's, fuckin', only the hero- OHH! Holy shit, found Food and Water and a Chocolate Bar.
Mark: Hell yeah- Don't take my chocolate.
Bob: DON'T change the subject!
Mark: Hey, alright, you wanna see me eat?
Mark: THERE. DONE. I ATE.
Mark: You happy?!
*both laugh*
Bob: You know, honestly, I didn't see anything.
Mark: It- I SWEAR!
Bob: I sorta thought there'd be more visual eating going on.
Mark: Eh- Duh- I- Suh- I *inhale* See? I ATE, okay?
Mark: Right there, do you hear that?
Bob: OH! Oh wait! I heard it!
Bob: You were perfectly still, but I did hear some crunching!
Mark: *laughs* GOOD!
Bob: Did you just magically- did you just teleport it into your mouth there?
Mark: I did SOMETHING, it doesn't matter. I ATE, you should be happy.
Bob: I think this connection you have to this rock is unhealthy, I just want to say that.
Mark: It's okay. It's fine. It's FINE.
Bob: It's not fine.
Bob: When you say it's fine, I know it's not fine.
Mark: It's...
Bob: You can't just say that.
Mark: It's fine.
Mark: *It's* fine.
Bob: It's... FINE.
Mark: It's FFFFFFFFFFFFine.
Mark: Okay, so, alright, here's the $20 Question:
Mark: Should we go into this town and risk Radiation Poisoning?
Bob: Sure.
Mark: Or should we skirt outside and go back towards the river where I came from?
Bob: We could skirt outside and- and... hunt down barrels and stuff
Bob: and try and get minor loot.
Mark: *chuckle* Just "hunt", "HUNT the Prairie Barrels!" Try desperately, not to die.
Bob: You know what? YOU laugh, but it's not that funny.
Mark: Alright, okay, alright then, "fine."
Bob: It's not, this isn't a joke, okay?
Mark: Alright, fine... fine.
Mark: Fuh- Guess who found-
Bob: I've literally died 3 times today.
Mark: Woah.
Bob: Literally, 3 times today.
Mark: Guess who found High-Quality Metal while you were just makin' fun of me!
Bob: Definitely wasn't you, you lazy piece of-
Mark: I GOT HIGH-QUALITY METAL! RIGHT NOW!!!
I'M LOOKING AT IT IN MY INVENTORY.
Mark: 23 OF 'EM!
Bob: Okay, right... uh huh...
Mark: I could make a WEAPON FLASHLIGHT right now!
Bob: Sure... Uh huh...
Mark: I could make a Muzzle Boost! A Muzzle Brake!
Bob: Those all sound very useful for the family, Tony.
Mark: I'm gonna make m-
Mark: I am NOT Tony Horton!
Mark: I am not.
Bob: *laughs loudly*
Bob: *laughs louder*
Mark: I'll never be THAT good.
Bob: DAH! It's fackin' Radiation Poisoning. Fack!
Mark: Don't go in too deep. I'm still on the outskirts of it.
Bob: I'm alright.
Mark: Just don't die, we need to survive. We're doin' good.
Mark: And by the way I'm making an ACOUSTIC GUITAR for you!
Bob: Oh, thank you.
Mark: Yeah!
Bob: I've been wanting one of those, actually.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Mandy (Bob's wife) says it's hot when you play acoustic guitar.
Mark: Is that true?
Bob: She likes it. She wants me to- well,
Bob: She doesn't want me to learn it, but I want to learn it 'cause I want to do it.
Bob: And she says "That's cool, because it's hot."
Mark: Cool, cool. That sounds really cool. Also, do you- ?
Bob: I will learn how to play some of those Beatles songs.
Mark: Yeaaah, that's what gets all the ladies.
Bob: Like "Hey There Delilah."
Mark: Plain White Beatles, "Hey There De-"
Mark: AHHh, Radiation! Hoof!
Bob: Please don't Radiation me. There's a box here I would really love to procure.
Mark: Where did you GO? Where'd you go?
Bob [sing-song]: I got a medkit, I got a medkit!
Bob: I'm like way on the far side of town.
Bob: When we hit the town, I went LEFT around it.
Mark: Hmm, okay.
Bob: So I'm like, I can see the Lighthouse now.
Mark: Oh, you can?
Bob: I went like AROUND the town, and I'm on the far side of it now, and I can see the Lighthouse.
Mark: Ah, okay, I can kinda see it too. I'm on the far side of it too, but...
Bob: Did you go through the middle, or...?
Mark: I kinda went towards the middle, but now I'm on the outskirts.
Mark: I'm by a cement wall and whatnot.
Bob: I think I'm outside that wall from you maybe?
Mark: Hmm, I'm on the interior, by Blue Containers, is where I am.
Bob: Uhh, I don't see any containers...
Bob: I see like a very rusty big, like Factory Building.
Bob: Next to some silos.
Mark: Hmm.
Mark: HOW DID WE LOSE EACH OTHER AGAIN?
Bob: Wait wait wait, Blue Containers! I see you! I see you!
Mark: Okay, alright.
Bob: I'm over HERE!
Mark: You see ME? Like ME, the person?
Bob: To you RIGHT! Over here!
Mark: Oh, I see you. Okay. BABY!
Mark: Baby I missed you! I missed those sweet baps!
*blubbering noises*
Mark: Alright.
Bob: Onward to the Lighthouse, I guess?
Mark: Sure, why not? It's so foggy.
Bob: Oh, I'm actually Starving to death.
Bob: I'm gonna eat some of this Food I found.
Mark: Yeah, you do that. I KNOW I saw Animals around here.
Mark: There's gotta be. I am a provid- I see! I see an animal.
Mark: It's a horse! It's a pferd! A pferd!
Bob: Oh Jesus.
Mark: EIN PFERD!
Mark: I'm gonna shoot that horse.
Bob: Oh ja~, you are learning German?
Mark: Uh, ja~! Jawohl!
Mark: Okay, here we go, I'm gonna shoot, I'm gonna fuck this horse up.
Bob: I'm gonna watch you fuck this horse, okay?
Mark: Okay.
Mark: That didn't.
Bob: THAT was awful.
Mark: Sorry, hang on, just gotta aim a little higher.
Mark: WOAHohohohahaha! OHHH!!!
Bob: Right in the fucking NECK! Oh my GOD!
Bob: Come here, horse!
Mark: OH! Get horsed!
Mark: Oh my- oh my god. Oh my god!
Bob: I got "Raw Chicken Breast" from the horse!
Mark [laughing]: Hu-hu-hu-hu-hu-hu~ Wha-a-a-at?
Bob: I got "Bone Fragments" and "Leather" and "Raw Chicken Breast" and "Animal Fat."
Mark [laughing]: Jesus Christ!
Mark [laughing]: You fucked that horse so hard!
Bob: I thought you wanted me to.
Mark: It was just like, instant, like "Oh! Right in the neck," and then immediately you set to work!
Mark: Jesus!
Mark: Alright, I found some mushrooms, so I'm gonna eat those.
Bob: Yeah, mushrooms is good.
Mark: Alright, just, but, y'know,
Mark: We could share, we could make a campfire.
Mark: Maybe you could-
Bob: Yeah, if we could make a campfire, I can cook those Chicken Boobs.
Mark: Maybe you could not kill me, because I feel like- I feel-
Bob: What? You feel differently about me now?
Mark: Yeah, a little bit.
Bob: Now that you've seen me how I REALLY like to be?
Bob: Now that you've seen my TRUE self?
Bob: Are these Railroad Tracks over here?
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: Alright, so I know there was more Deer by the um... by the river here.
Bob: By the loo-hoot? Wow, I don't know what I was just trying to say, but it made my face explode.
Mark: *giggle*
Bob: BAPL-LAHOOF?!
Mark: How you doin' on Food? What are you at?
Bob: Pretty good, I've got about 48 Food.
Mark: Cool, okay, so... I-
Mark: That Chocolate Bar, like, did me good! I'm at 200 right now.
Bob: Oh shit dude!
Mark: That chocolate bar was amazing!
Bob: Chocolate Bar is The Shit!
Mark: I'm gonna look in the crafting menu how to make-
Bob: I'll never talk bad about chocolates again!
Mark: Ok, "Fire." You need 100 Wood to make a Fire. Do you have 100 Wood?
Bob: I can make a camp- I'm currently cramping a crampfire.
Mark: Cool, cramp that cramfire! Schmarf that!
Bob: I'm cramping it!
Bob: Where are you at?
Mark: I'm right behind you, Bobby Boy.
Bob: Should we just put it down right here?
Mark: Sure, on this hill's good enough for me!
Bob: 20 seconds left.
Mark: Hell yeah, man.
Bob: Let's do my campfire dance.
Mark: You do that!
Mark: Hiaya, hoya, haya, ho ya...
Bob: Wow, that... really went in a direction, huh?
Mark [softly]: Yeah, yeah.
Bob: I was just dancin' like regular.
Mark: AH, Oh yeah! Get it!
Bob: Are you just doing some squat thrusts?
Mark: You know what's amazing?
Mark: I HAVE been doing these workout DVDs lately.
Mark: Uh, I LOVE Shaun T, he's like my favorite fitness instructor ever in the history of forever.
Mark: But he has this other thing called SIZE, which is like his dance class.
Mark: It's FUCKIN' AMAZING! Like I can't dance for-
Mark: WOAH! Fire!
Mark: I can't dance for SHIT, but, MAN!
Mark: It makes me want to dance!
Mark: Wait, "Hold down Use", "Open Storage Container."
Bob: I just put two chicken-things...
Bob: What're you puttin' in there? What is that?
Mark: I didn't put anything in there.
Bob: Oh, charcoal appeared. Okay. I'm cooking chickens.
Mark: Cool. How did--How did a horse--?
Mark [high pitched]: How the f--How'd a--How'd a horse get a chicken breast?
Bob: I guess they didn't wanna give up on their whole:
Bob: "Oh you get chicken from everything--hahaha"
Bob: 'Cause, remember that used to be a-a big-big Rust joke.
Mark: I-I mean, you're-you're not wrong, but o-okay, this ca-this calls for--
Mark: AH, I'm burning I'm on fire, fuck.
Bob: Jesus man.
Mark: *plays guitar* Ya like that?
Bob: HAAHHHAAAAAAHAA
Bob: You just played the same non-chord over and over again?
Mark: Yep!
Bob: Oh, oh How are you doing that?
Mark: I'm Right Clicking.
Mark: Oh FUCK it.
Bob: *laughs* You're also pointing it at me, like a gun!
Mark: *chuckles*
Bob: *laughs heartily*
Mark: Are you, uh, SEDUCED yet, baby?
Bob: Oh god, oh...
Bob: Woah, if I move around you...
Mark: Yeah?
Bob: It sounds crazy as SHIT!
Mark: It sounds a little different for me too. Why?
Bob: Alright, we have 2 Cooked Chicken Breasts now.
Mark: *giggle* I just-
Bob: Woah, what are you doing?
*music changes pitch as he turns*
Bob: What are you doing? *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: AHHHhhooaayeeeeoooo!
Bob: Wait wait wait, can you give it to me? I have an idea.
Mark: Yeah, hang on, I'll drop it on the ground.
Bob: Oh I can make my own. Fuck it.
Mark: It takes like 50 seconds. Here, do your idea right now.
Mark: Oh shit, my git- MY GUITAR!!! *laugs*
Bob: Oh Jesus Christ! *laugs*
Mark: My guitar!
Bob: *laughs*
Bob: Are you ready for this shit?
Mark: I am SO ready, yeah show me.
Mark: Oh my god, it IS like a gun! Jesus!
Bob: Yeah, I- You hold it like a gun.
Mark: Alright, go for it.
Bob: Ready?
Mark: Yeah.
*guitar starts*
Mark: *chuckle* Jeeesus Christ!
Mark: Alright, you do that, I'm gonna spin around you.
Bob: *laughs* I think I'm...
Bob: ...summoning the devil right now!
Mark [laughing]: Oh my god.
Mark: The fuck? Who PROGRAMMED that?
Mark: Who the fuck programmed that? *laughs*
Mark: Oh jeez.
Bob: I wonder if you can actually learn to play a song on this, hang on.
Mark: Oh, I don't know...
Mark: I'm gonna make another Rock, 'cause mine's about to break.
Mark: Oh GOD, the SUN'S goin' down!
Mark: Hey! I'm getting "Comfort," oh that's nice!
Mark: Uh, did you eat those Chicken?
Bob: No, uh, you want one?
Mark: No no, I'm good. I got 134. Tell me how much Food it gives you after you eat it.
Bob: Aw, that's fuckin' bull. It put me from 38 to 78 and gave me some health.
Mark: Eh, go ahead and eat 'em all.
*guitar plucks*
Mark: Oh that's nice.
Bob: I'm trying to play "Kum Ba Ya," it's fuckin' hard!
*plucks notes*
Bob: Oh my god!
Mark: Yeah, that was it!
Bob: So aiming higher and lower changes the tone.
Mark: THAT'S what it is, that's so weird.
Mark: It's just like someone who'd actually be good at it would just be:
Mark: Ehyalulauuuaaaaee!
Bob: *burst laughter*
*guitar goes crazy*
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Am I doin' it?
Mark: Yer doin' it Bahb!
Bob: What's an easy song to play?
Mark: Uh, "Twinkle."
Bob: Here, I'll play "Row Row Row Your Boat!"
Mark: Oh yeah, that's good.
*plucks off key*
Mark: *giggles*
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: This is the most horrifying thing
Bob: *laughs harder*
Mark: Just, your shadow, the campfire, the fact-
Mark: Ooh! Christmas Present!
Mark: Ooh there's two!
Mark: I'll go for the far one.
Bob: I'll play my guitar so you can always know where I'm at!
Mark: Jesus, that actually IS a good point!
Bob: It sounds like Satanic Music though.
Mark: It's so bad!
Bob: When you're running and it's just like:
Bob: BeedleBeedleBerDeeLeedle!
Mark: Christmas Present! DerTinkDankTerDerTayTer!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Alright, what have we got?
Bob: Good thing they put that in the game!
Mark: I got, uh, four Small and one Medium. What do you got?
Bob: OH MY GOD! The LIGHTS all went out when I opened my fucking present!
Mark: Hang on, I'm coming with the fuckin'... Did you find them?
Bob: Yeah, I got my torch out. *giggles*
Mark: Ooh, there's another one over there!
Mark: If you combine enough Small Presents, it'll turn into a Big Present.
Mark: That's what I-
Bob: TWO CHRISTMAS PRESENTS!
*guitar goes nuts*
Mark: Hang on, wup, missed.
Mark: You're just a shadow in the darkness of a Guitar Player! Fuck!
Mark: Ok, I got five Small Present, um, I'm gonna go back to the campfire.
Mark: So if you give me one more Small Present, apparently it turns into a Big Present.
Mark: Yeah, "Collect 10 to upgrade to a Larger Present."
Mark: So give me one of your Small.
Bob: I have five Small Presents.
Mark: Yeah, give me one.
Bob: Oh, I dropped 'em all, whatever.
Mark: Uh, I'll drop the four, back there. Right there.
Bob: This guitar- I also have my own guitar now, so you're welcome to have a guitar if you so desire.
Bob: There you go sir.
Mark: "Unwrap." "Unwrap." I got a Teddy Bear?!
Mark: The fuck is THAT gonna do me? Oh well, I got a Salvaged Cleaver.
Mark: You want a Salvaged Cleaver?
*strums guitar drunkenly*
Mark: That's really nice, man.
Bob: Nah, I just wanna jam out.
Mark: Alright, that's good, you jam.
Bob: That's basically all I wanna do for the rest of my life.
Mark: I mean, that's pretty good. Our lives aren't gonna last very long out here, so, y'know?
Bob: I got three Med Syringes and a Candy Cane.
Mark: Oo, EAT that Candy Cane, it gives SO much Health and Food. Eat it!
Bob: Eat.
Bob: Oh wow, fuck yeah, 450 Foods now.
Mark: I know, right? Yeah! Alright.
Mark: So, I think that's as good a place as any to stop, right?
*sad strums*
Mark: I mean, we didn't do anything except jam out on a guitar and-
Bob: You should get your guitar out and we should do this, we should end this with a rock jam sesh.
Mark: Yeah, I'll do it, I got it right here bruh. I don't have a strap for it, but I got my guitar.
Bob: You could just hold it like a gun, that's fine.
Mark: That's fine, I'll do that.
Mark: I'll just sh- point it at the camera.
Bob: YOU be the judge, audience.
Mark: Wait, I got it.
Bob: Who wins the jam-off?
*off key "Smoke On The Water" by Deep Purple*
*slow and sloppy attempt at "Smoke On The Water" by Deep Purple*
Mark: Dude, I did it! Did you hear that?
Bob: *strums forever* *giggles*
Bob: I'm too busy amusing myself, sorry.
Mark: Hey, here's an E-Chord. *strums correctly*
Bob: Yeah, that sounds like guitar.
Mark: *strums quickly*
Mark: I did it dude, I did it.
Bob: Hey, there's an airplane over there.
Mark: Oh shit. Since there's no one on here, maybe we should actually go for the drops.
Mark: Nah.
Bob: I'm lazy.
Mark: Yeah, it's true.
Bob: I'm pretty much happy with my guitar as well.
Mark: Okay, alright, this is a good enough place to end it, so,
Bob: *strums*
Mark: Thank you everybody, so much for watching.
Mark: We jammed out, and we had a lot of fun.
Mark: And we are not dead, which is kinda nice.
Mark: I mean, we're gonna be dead, but we're not dead now.
Mark: So, any closing thoughts, Bob?
*"Crazy La Paint" by MiniMusicMan plays*
Bob: *strums vigorously*
Bob: Trying to summon Satan, hang on...
Bob: Solid.
Mark: That was good, that was good.
Mark: Okay, so thank you everybody so much for watching, and, as always,
Mark: We will see YOU, in the next video, buh bye!
*"Crazy La Paint" intensifies*
Subscibe to mark and Bodacious Betty And demian yvon!!!!!! BUH BYE <3
*music slides down*
*music slides out*